on va parler des individus fichess c'est
un sujet qui est au cœur de l'actualité
ces derniers jours après l'attentat bien
entendu qui a eu lieu à haras vendredi
dernier ce jour-là Mohamed mogutchov a
assassiné Dominique Bernard professeur
dont on a parlé hier avec un ancien
élève à lui qui nous disait que c un
professeur formidable un professeur de
lycée euh il a blessé donc trois autres
personnes après une attaque au couteau
cet homme d'une vingtaine d'anées né en
Russie est arrivé en France en 2008 il
était fich S et suivi par les
renseignements ce qui n'a pas manqué
d'ouvrir les débats sur le traitement
que la France porte aux individus
fichiers s euh pour répondre à toutes
nos questions et d'ailleurs la question
je vais vous la poser doit-on exp
expulser les f les fichiers s étranger
doit-on les expulser oui non vous
répondez également chez vous pour
répondre aussi avec cette question on a
camichz qui est exceptionnelle qui est
le porte la porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur on va regarder ces images
d'ailleurs de Géral daranin qui oppose
qui oppose sa proposition de loi celle
en vigueur actuellement et on
l'accueille juste après euh vous allez
voir et dans ce que dit Géral d'Anin on
sent bien que
c'est une question de justice he on l'a
dit il aimerait bien faire le maximum
Gérard daranin mais forcément derrière
ça suit pas c'estàdire qu'il faudrait
que comme on l'a dit souvent police et
justice travaillent main dans la main et
il y a énormément j'ai vu j'ai vu tiens
j'ai vu une secrétaire d'État aussi ce
matin qui parlait et qui disait il y a
énormément de lois à changer et
qu'aujourd'hui le code pénal ne
correspond pas à la société
d'aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui revient à chaque fois et pourtant on
a l'impression que ça bouge pas alors on
va voir regardez le texte immigration
tel que nous l'avons proposé et adopté
par la commission de dév du Sénat nous
aurait permis de pouvoir obtenir la
levée des protections du terroriste
d'aras en France si vous êtes arrivé sur
le territoire national avant l'âge de 13
ans si vous êtes marié sur le territoire
national avec une Française si vous avez
des enfants nés en France il y a des
protections qui vous empêchent de vous
expulser sauf si vous êtes vous touchez
aux intért in fondamentaux de la nation
donc le terrorisme ce n'était pas le cas
de cette personne don je rappelle qu'il
n'avait pas de casier judiciaire qui
était suivi par les services de
renseignement depuis moins de 3 mois et
pour lequel nous n'avions que des
soupçons et aucune preuve d'être en lien
avec une entreprise terroriste voilà
gerérard hermana le dit bien ils n'ont
fait qu'appliquer la loi donc forcément
compliqué de dire est-ce que cet
attentat aurait pu être évité puisque il
n'a fait qu'appliquer la loi et en
soutexte de ce que je ressens pas de
poser la question à cichz mais c'est que
il faudrait que les lois changent et que
on puisse faire quelque chose là-dessus
et forcément le le le ministre de
l'intérieur quand il y a des drames
comme ça il s'en réjouit pas contraire
il essaie peut-être de faire bouger les
choses j'espère que ça va être au Garde
des sauts maintenant d'essayer de
peut-être faire quelque chose au plus
vite sur ces cas-là merci camichz
porte-parole du ministère de l'Intérieur
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
comment expliquez-vous donc on on l'a on
l'a voilà il l'a expliqué Géral mais qu'
un homme fichier qui est suivi par la
DGSI puisse commettre un attentat on
peut pas être derrière lui toute la
journée en fait c'est ça on aurait
vraiment vraiment voulu déjouer cette
attentat comme on en a déjoué plein
d'autres euh la réalité des choses c'est
que on avait mis le maximum sur cet
individu qu'on connaissait il y avait ce
qu'on appelle un suivi actif on savait
qu'il était radicalisé on avait mis ce
qu'on appelle des techniques de
renseignement donc des outils techniques
notamment des écoutes hein je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails mais c'était
principalement ça pour écouter ces
conversations savoir s'il échangeait
avec quelqu'un sur des projets euh on
avait aussi une une surveillance humaine
donc en gros des des filatures à des
moments clés euh on a un petit peu
évoqué dans les médias cette
interpellation qui a eu lieu la veille
pour aller un peu plus loin dans cette
surveillance aller chercher des choses
dans son téléphone euh par exemple pour
pour essayer d'en savoir plus et on
avait aucun aucun élément qui allait
nous dire qu'il allait passer à l'acte
et donc voilà on est sur ce qu'on
redoute le plus c'est-à-dire quelqu'un
qu'on connaît qui est radicalisé mais
comment savoir à quel moment
psychologiquement psychiatriquement il
va décider de faire l'irréparable et
c'est ce qui est arrivé vendredi il
avait quand même un énorme passif en
2014 il avait été placé en centre de
rétention avant son expulsion n'ayant
pas obtenu de demande d'asile et il y a
quelques années il avait fait de la
garde à vue pour avoir frappé sa mère
qui n'avait finalement pas porté plainte
en étant fich en S euh est-ce que on
aurait pas pu est-ce qu'il aurait pas dû
être expulsé à ce moment-là directement
c'est surtout sa famille qui est connue
lui il est arrivé en France il avait 5
ans c'était un enfant euh mais sa
famille était connue d'abord son père
qui était très connu son père on a
réussi à l'expulser en 2018 après je
vais vous épargner tout ça mais après
tout un tas de demande d'asile de
recours de sollicitation devant une
commission de de recours enfin c'est
c'est une procédure vraiment très très
complexe en matière de droit des
étrangers donc le père on arrive à
l'expulser pour de l'islam radical euh
le le reste de la famille à un moment on
a cette volonté d'expulsion ça va très
loin ça va jusqu'à ce placement en
centre de rétention administrative donc
c'est vraiment le moment où on organise
la logistique pour renvoyer les
personnes à l'étranger donc on en était
là et il y a des manifestation qui sont
dans leur droit et avec leur logique
militante qui font pression sur le
politique le ministre de l'Intérieur de
de l'époque manuel Vals et
donc et ben il y a une marche arrière et
cette famille n'est n'est pas expulsée
et puis après l'enfant grandit il
devient majeur il refait des demandes
d'asile et cetera et cetera à un moment
même on voulait aussi expulser la mer
mais là cette fois-ci on n pas eu le
laisser passer consulaire avec la Russie
parce qu'après il y a des questions
diplomatiques donc bref il a pas pas une
his une association qui a qui a voulu
que la famille ne soit pas expé si mais
les associations vous savez c'est leur
c'est c'est c'est ils sont dans le droit
des étrangers il les aident dans leur
recours c'est aussi leur leur manière de
de voir les choses il fa faudrait que
quand il y a une décision de justice une
décision administrative tout le monde la
respecte que ce soit l'état les
associations et que on mette à exécution
ce qu'on comme ça je v vous dire camicha
forcément vous je le sais on en a déjà
discuté ensemble quand il se passe un
drame comme ça sachezle que ce soit le
ministre de l'intérieur ou camichaise la
porte-parole elle est effondrée voilà je
le sais et c'est pas de c'est pas du
mytho je vous le dis elle est effondré
et là sur un truc comme ça c'est vrai
qu'à un moment aussi il faut que tout le
monde respecte les cision je suis désolé
à un moment quand il y a une décision on
prend pas une décision pour rien voilà
donc forcément les associations ils font
un travail exceptionnel mais là c'est
c'est c'est il faut faut respecter les
décisions je suis désolé quand il y a
une décision qui est prise sur des
individus de tels individus c'est que
derrière il y a eu une enquête il y a la
décision elle tombe pas de n'importe où
la décision elle a été qu' a une enquête
derrière c'est pas ils ont pas choisi
comme ça ils ont dit bah lui oui on va
cette famille là on va les expulser
c'est qu'ils ont des infos donc
forcément les associations je sais
qu'elles aimeraient aider tout le monde
et que et forcément elles font un
travail exceptionnel et pour 95 % des
gens 80 même 19 % des gens qu'elles
aident qui qui don qui qui doivent être
aidés et qui qui voilà et ben il y a 1 %
de personnes bah forcément qui commettre
peuvent commettre des des des drames
comme celui-là et là aujourd'hui bah
c'est ce 1 % qui a qui a ôté la vie
d'unun d'un professeur et qui a mis
voilà sa famille qui maintenant sen
remettra jamais je poser une question il
y a un instant doit-on expulser les fich
s étranger plébiscite ici puisque tout
le monde dit oui sauf Gilles Verdez
alors on a envie de savoir pourquoi non
mais parce qu'on peut pas c'est un V
pieux je veux bien dire oui mais c'est
n'importe quoi moi je suis sur la ligne
de Monsieur Darmanin il a cité 193
fichiers s dangereux oui aujourd'hui il
a parlé de 11 personnes russes oui mais
même cela Cyril on ne pourra pas les
expulser parce qu'il y aura pas de
laisser passer consulaire parce qu'il a
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme c'est impossible d'expulser on
narrive pas c'est l'Algérie le Maroc la
Tunisie la Russie on ne peut pas expuler
là-bas mais on ne peut pas donc c'est
pas la peine de dire oui raison ou dem
toi ton mais moi non parce que moi je
suis légaliste on si si regardez les
Russes aujourd'hui monsieur Darmanin il
dit il y a 11 russes il a cité mais
c'est russes comme il y a plus de lien
avec la Russie on va les expulser vers
où nulle part justement alors justement
camich peut nous répondre
justement alors je pense qu'on est on
est tous d'accord au fond doit-on
expulser les fichess oui on doit après
comment comment on s'y prend là dans
notre fichier déradicalisé il y a 5000
personnes il y en a 500 qui sont
étrangers en situation irrégulière c'est
ces 500 là qu'on cle prioritairement il
y en a la moitié en gros ils sont déjà
en prison donc c'est à la sortie de
prison où on essaiera de les renvoyer il
y en a qui sont déjà dans les centres de
rétention en attente d'éloignement et il
y en a quelques-uns qui sont assignal
résidence donc il sont surveillés qui
peuvent pas quitter leur lieu après
comment on les renvoie a c'est laisser
passer consulaire pour ce qui est de la
Russie Gérald d'Anin il a décidé que
même si il y avait une guerre depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs années
maintenant entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
on allait reprendre les relations
diplomatiques avec la Russie sur ce
point précis et il y a 11 personnes
nominatives qui ont été ciblées et on
est en discussion avec la Russie sur ce
point précis nonobstant la la la guerre
en cours donc on peut et par le passé
par exemple on a eu des fois des des
mesures de rétorsion à l'endroit
d'autres pays par exemple limiter les
les visas euh pour dans la négociation
en fait diplomatique avec les autres
pays dire bah si vous reprenez pas ces
personnes dangereuses qui sont vos
ressortissant euh nous on vous donne pas
de visa pour des étudiants ou des jeunes
travailleurs qui veulent venir en France
donc il y a quand même des relations
diplomatiques à avoir mais là où je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est que c'est du
cas par cas ça demande une énergie folle
mais c'est aussi ça la souveraineté des
États on peut pas imposer à un état en
ressortissant s'il ne le reconnaît pas
il a sa souveraineté il a son espace et
ça ne marchera que si on arrive à
réaliser cette relation diplomatique et
c'est c'est c'est ce à quoi on
s'attellele de nouveau notamment avec la
Russie alors justement on sent en ce
moment que le climat est extrêmement
tendu ministre de l'Intérieur nous l'a
rappelé encore ces derniers jours est-ce
qu'en ce moment vous
faites vous faites des surveillance
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus importante
sur ces individus est-ce qu'en ce moment
il y a vraiment une vigilance accrue
déjà ce que nous a demandé le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est de passer au peigne
fin tous les radicalis notamment les
radicalisés étrangers donc aujourd'hui
s'est tenu dans toutes les préfectures
des réunions avec les services de
renseignement donc la DGSI dont on a
beaucoup parlé les services de
renseignement territorial aussi d'autres
services de renseignement comme le
renseignement dans les prisons en milieu
pénitentiaire il y a eu ces réunions qui
sont tenues aujourd'hui partout en
France dans tous les départements sous
lesgide des préfets et avec les
procureurs de la République moi j'étais
tout à l'heure dans le Val de Marne et
Madame la préfè avait une liste de
presque une centaine de personnes et un
par un ces personnes
les situations de ces personnes ont été
évoquées et à chaque fois la question
c'est est-ce que ça cette personne elle
est étrangère en situation régulière
quel est le niveau de dangerosité est-ce
qu'il y a des signalements par exemple
de l'école des voisins de la famille
est-ce qu'il y a des nouveaux éléments
par rapport à cette situation qu'est-ce
qu'on fait collégialement et sous
l'autorité du préfet et à chaque fois
c'est si elle est vraiment dangereuse et
qu'elle est régulière on peut lui
retirer son titre c'est-à-dire la faire
en sorte qu'elle ne reste plus en France
et si elle est irrégulière on peut
lancer l'éloignement la procédure avec
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
placement en centre de rétention donc ça
c'est ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui à
la demande du ministre de l'Intérieur et
j'ai appelé plusieurs préfets qui m'ont
tous dit que ces réunions elles avaient
lieu alors il y a des plus petits
départements le Val de Marne il y a
vraiment beaucoup de monde dans ce
fichier parce que c'est un gros
département mais ça a été le cas
aujourd'hui partout en France et c'est
comme ça au cas par cas avec aussi une
grande justice faut pas faire d'amalgame
il y a il y a aussi parfois des faux
signalements il y a des personnes qui
peent avoir un esprit de vengeance en
disant monsieur X il est radicalisé donc
il faut vraiment faire un travail
sérieux làd his fol on a vu je pour
citer que cette histoire enfin je ve
citer deux histoires on a vu cette cette
cette dame qui avait dit salam alkou
mais qui s'est retrouvé en en garde à
vue donc faut être très sérieux avec
tout ça et partager et partager aussi
après il y en a qu'un qui décide c'est
le préfet et le ministre de l'Intérieur
et quand on décide quelques chose il
faut y aller et être efficace dans la
décision qu' y a y a un attentat mine de
rien une attaque qui a été joué le jour
aussi parce que exactement puisquon a
attrapé un individu avec des tenant à
couteau qui avait des vidéos qui était
très voilà très compliqué
propagandeadiste voilà et justement une
question parce que cette personneel elle
a été interpellée et elle va être jugée
pour détention d'armes d'armes 6 mois
exactement
quand quand la police fait son travail
travail et rentre commissariat et dit
c'est incroyable on a déjoué
certainement un assassinat un attentat
peut-être une tuerie importante et que
ils apprennent ils le savent d'ailleurs
un jour ou de jours après que cette
personne va être juste jugée pour
détenenstion
d'armes est-ce que vous dites pas un
moment c'est pas vous c'est pas de
votreessort mais est-ce qu'à un moment
il y a pas des lois qu'il faudrait
revoir même pour
améliorer le travail des policiers je
vois des policiers tous les jours qui me
parlent à chaque fois dans la rue je
jure il m'arrête il me disent tiens cy
on a on en peut plus on est fatigué je
sais que vous le savez aussi on a des
des des voilà des cadences infernales et
en plus on n'est pas aidé parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on se qu'est-ce qui se
passe on va aller chercher des gars on
va les
mettre on va les on va les interpeller
et de jours après ils vont être dehors
on va devoir aller les rechercher à un
moment si on n'est pas aidé par la
justice on peut on peut on peut rien
faire et c'est ce qui ressort énormément
et dans le discours de du ministre de
l'intérieur on a senti aussi euh voilà
la volonté de dire je peux faire tout ce
que je veux et je fais un travail et je
le dis le ministère de l'Intérieur je
vous promets si je pense que c'est voilà
c'est ils travaillent comme des fous et
ils essaient de faire le mieux mais un
moment on a l'impression que Gérard
Gérard Darmanin dit j'ai besoin d'être
aidé parce que sinon je peux pas il y a
moi j'ai j'ai aimé il y a de lours il a
il a dit plein de fois il y a des des
choses que je ne peux pas faire parce
que derrière ça suivra pas donc est-ce
que c'est c'est c'est est-ce que c'est
c'est envisageable ça ou pas il faut pas
à mon avis opposer la justice et la
police parce que objectivement on
travail main dans la main ce qui est sûr
c'est que des fois pour les policiers
mais avant tout pour les victimes de
voir la sanction pénale peut-être pas à
la hauteur de les de leur espérance ça
peut être difficile après nous là ce qui
est de notre sort et ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est d'améliorer la chaîne
c'est-à-dire une fois qu'on sait par
exemple que la personne elle les Cope un
an de prison qu'elle va sortir de prison
à ce moment-là il faut pas la laisser
partir dans la nature il faut organiser
un suivi si on a plus de moyens
judiciaires et ben il faut mettre en
place des moyens administratifs de
renseignement pour continuer à la suivre
si on estime queelle a purgé sa peine
judiciaire c'est comme ça par contre il
faut pas la lâcher et la et la laisser
dans la nature c'est plutôt là-dessus
qu'on travaille après c'est toujours
possible de d'aggraver les sanctions
c'est-à-dire de dire la personne elle
risque pas 6 mois elle risque un an ou
elle risque non mais juste camich sur
sur désolé he vous coupez camichaz mais
sur ce cas précis on le voit bien cette
personne elle avait un couteau elle
avait des vidéos de propagande elle se
on sait qu'elle allait certainement
conna commettre un assassinat cette
personne si elle est dans 6 mois dehors
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire vous ça
va n coûter oui mais ça va nous coûter
des moyens des effectifs un
travoui bien sûr mais après chacun il
est il est jugé en fonction de ce qu'il
a commis là il se trouve que il avait
commis très peu c'était un commencement
d'acte une préparation et donc
légalement les peines sont beaucoup
pluses après il peut y avoir des lois
pour faire ce qu'on appelle une
aggravation des peines au lieu de
risquer 6 mois de prison on peut risquer
2 3 4 c'est vous dis vous travz main
dans la main avec la justice justement
ça c'est un cas je suis désolé cette
personne là tous ici et chez vous aussi
vous avez pas envie de la retrouver
dehors dans 6 mois et pour vous c'est un
travail titanesque parce que
vous allez voir lui mettre quelqu'un au
N c'est plus 10 personnes comme ça une
personne qu'on doit suivre en suivi
régulier c'est plus de 10 agents qu'il
faut agents de renseignement policier de
terrain et donc on on priorise aussi
c'est ça la vérité on va aller chercher
le haut du spectre les personnes les
plus dangereux pour mettre nos moyens de
renseignement humain et technique sur
ces personneslà parce que même si on est
300000 au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
a un moment on a des parce que ce que
vous dites camichz c'est que cette
personne quand elle va sortir dans 6
mois vous allez laattend la is derrière
elle avec les moyens de renseignement
mie Fall il aurait mie fallu vous
laisser un peu plus de temps et elle
sortira dans 2 ans à la limite voilà
mais bon dans 2 ans c'est pas pas
beaucoup mieux mais au moins c'est voilà
on gagne on gagne ce suivi des sortants
de prison ça existait pas avant les
attentats 2015-26 on l'a vraiment mis en
place à l'issue parce qu'il y a des gens
même qui ont commis des faits graves qui
vont ressortir après 10 ans de prison
par exemple c'est des gens jeunes
parfois et donc ils peuvent avoir 40 50
ans et la déradicalisation on sait
qu'elle est complexe ça marche des fois
et des fois ça échoue ement donc on sait
que il y a des personnes qu'on ne va
jamais lâcher et qui vont nous mobiliser
pendant de très très longues années
justement Mohamed m donc la la la
personne qui a commis cet attentat à
haras à votre avis elle va sortir un
jour pardon votre avis elle va sortir un
jour bien sû ce serait fou parce qu'elle
est très jeune avec les très jeunes
personne parce que même si elle prend il
y a une réclusion parfois une réclusion
à perpétuité ça existe encore sûr euh
après ça c'est vraiment des décisions
des juges aussi et puis et et puis les
personnes peuvent aussi changer euh mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une une peine une peine lourde la
déradicalisation ça ça ça ça existe
aussi dans 20 ans dans 30 ans après je
vais vous dire moi moi après Camille
vous avez raison de dire ça c'est vous
qui avez raison mais moi je vais pas
dire ce que j'en pense mais je suis
désolé j'ai pas envie de voir cette
personne dehors ni dans 30 ans ni dans
40 ans ni dans 50 ans et je pense que la
famille du professeur non plus ni ni ni
toutes les personnes qui ont été attaqué
par par ce ce ce ce ce terroriste on va
on va se retrouver dans dans un instant
à tout de suite on se retrouve